why is this show so bin jabal what makes
it that way six episodes helps its no 13
you can just watch it through sex on
Saturday you know yeah you can just get
that done on one day and how many have
you signed up for
how many season I'm not signed up for
for any we're talking about doing
another one and so we're just working
that okay when do you think you'd start
I don't know no idea we have to come on
now everyone's benched it and they want
to know when they can get more I don't
know I honestly don't know we just kind
of wait and see where the scripts coming
do you think this role has changed your
life in any way can you walk down the
street anymore not really it's easy for
lots of ways you know it's just really
great to play that role and kind of just
puts me in a different and I think
people can maybe see me definitely from
being a son and two more of these adult
roles what do you do tonight and this
and then and then see some friends this
one what's a good of it that's just kind
of seeing less people you don't get to
see very often so well obviously
you